[Music]
all of a sudden senator Bernie Sanders
of Vermont is the front-runner in the
Democratic race as if tonight Sanders
has by far the best chance in the whole
Democratic Party of getting the
nomination so how should you feel about
that well if you're conservatives
probably a little hard to take the whole
thing seriously for one thing it seemed
to come out of nowhere nobody expects
that nobody on TV warned you was gonna
happen for another thing Sanders isn't
half as gut-level offensive as someone
like say Elizabeth Warren
unlike Warren Sanders is obviously
sincere about what he believes he means
it he's got the right enemies to seenin
appears to hate Bernie Sanders every bit
as much as they hate Donald Trump that's
a plus and like everyone else on the
left Sanders talks mostly about
economics rather than Putin and
non-binary bathrooms and it's refreshing
to hear someone focus on things that
matter for once plus it's not like
Sanders is gonna win the presidency you
keep hearing people on both sides saying
there is no possibility no chance in the
world that Bernie Sanders will get
elected president in November and that
sounds right basically the guy calls
himself a socialist come on now this is
America that's what we're telling
ourselves but are we absolutely sure
that that's true
last yourself.this who was the last
candidate they told you on television
could never ever win oh yeah the current
president so ignore the people on TV
they're morons they lack wisdom they
lack imagination they're almost always
wrong about everything
of course Bernie Sanders could win the
general election a year from now we
could be in the first months of a Bernie
Sanders administration and this would be
a completely different country what kind
of country would it be well tonight
we're beginning a series on Bernie
Sanders is America we take Sanders
seriously we think you should take him
seriously too so we're starting tonight
with Sanders his views on immigration
that's a topic that affects this country
on every level for decades Sanders had
what would now be considered
conservative views on immigration he
cared about higher wages for workers
that was his issue mass immigration
lowers wages so Sanders was against it
it's that simple then Sanders ran for
president and his views
changed completely now Sanders is as
radical and immigration as anyone else
in the race for example he's come out
against virtually all deportations all
watch a moratorium on deportations for
the 99% of the people is nothing to be
cynical about I think that is a
significant step forward and the
undocumented community would be very
proud of that ending ninety nine percent
of deportations to please the
undocumented community you should know
that that number includes violent felons
Sanders went on to say that only if an
illegal alien commits a quote terrible
terrible crime only then Sanders quote
might consider deporting that person
might now Sanders would have to change
any laws to do this he could simply
order federal authorities to stop
deportations he could do that day one
and that's his plan imagine what that
would mean for this country foreign
nationals commit crimes and we can't
send them home but Sanders wouldn't stop
there he's planning to unilaterally
enact many pieces of the new way forward
act that's the lunatic piece of
legislation we've covered on the show
extensively it's designed to protect
criminal aliens that's the point of it
Sanders has pledged to end the ban on
deported criminals reentering the United
States why is that a good idea he's
pledged to eliminate expedited removal
that's the policy that allows obvious
illegal aliens to be kicked out of the
country swiftly over he's promised to
give discretion to immigration judges so
they can protect any illegal aliens who
somehow beat the odds and face actual
deportation Sanders is also vowed to end
all workplace immigration raids so that
big business will be able to raw an
illegal immigrant labor with impunity
that's something he spent 30 years
attacking now he's for it and ending
those immigration raids will be easy
since Sanders is planning to abolish ice
on day one through an executive order we
will repeal all of trumps racist
immigration executive orders
we will end the ice raids that are
terrorizing communities all across
America of course businesses will have
two important more of that illegal
exploited labor that Sanders is suddenly
for because Sanders is also promising an
amnesty for all current illegal aliens
in this country that's more than 22
million people of course that's a move
that will change the electoral balance
in this country permanently forever and
that's the real point leadless to say
bringing there's no illegal workers
won't be difficult Sanders plans to
decriminalize the illegal border
crossings and abolish the border patrol
what is this this is what radical open
borders policy looks like Sanders is
arguing that everyone on earth has the
effective right to come to this country
anytime and receive the benefits of
citizenship in the Sanders
administration those benefits would
include but will not be limited to free
college free health care and full
eligibility for food stamps and Welfare
now we're not making this up for
partisan reasons or to slam Bernie
Sanders because sublet looks like he's
gonna be the nominee this has been out
there the whole time no one's mentioning
it but it's all on tape
Sanders brags about all of it watch I
believe that health care is a human
right senator would you include the 11
million undocumented when I talk about
health care being a human right last
time I heard that undocumented people
are human beings as well we need the
best educated population in the world
that means we're gonna make our public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and open that to the undocumented as
well so why is anybody talking about
this people are jumping up and down on
both sides on television because sanders
praised Fidel Castro because Sanders has
a self-described Democratic Socialist
that's bad there's no doubt but is it
worse than what he believes on policy
it's not even close you know what's way
worse than anything he's ever said about
Fidel Castro his belief his argument
that anyone on the planet who sneaks
into the United States should get free
health care and free college tuition
that's the case he's making so here's
the obvious question what would that do
to our
medical system in our universities how
long before they collapsed not long
these are some of the best things in our
countries what we brag about gone how do
we pay for all of this by the way and if
it's such a great idea why is no other
nation considering doing it why is no
other nation ever done this Sanders has
no answers for those questions the most
basic question and in fact it becomes
angry if you ask him he clearly doesn't
care about the consequences of his plans
why there's really only one possible
answer because he doesn't care about the
United States or its future it's obvious
that Sanders hates the country he seeks
to lead there's no other explanation for
it and that is a very dangerous quality
in a president this show will continue
to bring you a series on what life would
be like under a Bernie Sanders
administration because there's a lot
there and none of it's gotten attention
it's more than just praising Castro
trust us